اهلي صاروا حوالي اربعين سنه بفرنسا انا
مولود هون نشا اسامه في عائله فرنسيه من
اصول فلسطينيه السوريه كانت قد هاجرت منذ
عقودا للعيش في فرنسا ورغم انتمائه الوثيق
للبلد الذي ولد فيه الا انه لم يتخلى يوما
عن جذوره الاصليه على قيمنا يعني اهل يعني
كتير اشتغلوا على موضوع انه يعني
يرسوا فينا
القيام الاسلاميه وقيام العربيه وبهمنا
دائما انه يكون ان ارتباط بحضارتنا
تبقى فرنسا في طليعه الدول التي تعتبر
قبله للمهاجرين في العالم عراق مختلفه
عبرت من هنا وعاشت على ارضها لتمتزج بنسيج
شعبها وتصبح جزءا لا يتجزا من هويتها
الديموقرافيه عشره في المئه من سكان
فرنساهم مهاجرون هذا ما كشفته دراسه
ديموغرافيه جديده اجريت لاول مره منذ عشر
سنوات ويلاحظ الخبراء الذين اشرفوا على
الدراسه ان المهاجرين في فرنسا اكثر
ارتباطا بالدين من بقيه السكان بحيث يحتل
الاسلام المرتبه الاولى
الهجره هي ظاهره تاريخيه كانت حظيره دائما
في فرنسا نلاحظ انه منذ عام 2000 بدا
الارتفاع في نسبه المهاجرين في السكان
الفرنسيين ولدينا ايضا زياده في الهجره
لاسباب انسانيه ظهرت خاصه منذ ازمه
اللاجئين في عام 2015 قبل 50 عاما كان
اغلب المهاجرين في فرنساهم من جنوب اوروبا
اما اليوم زاد تنوعهم وياتون بشكل اساسي
من المغرب العربي وافريقيا واسيا وتشكل
النساء نصف عددهم زينه العربيه باريس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات